the new snow white lady who is notably
not white so we call her sand beige is
thrilled that they're remaking Snow
White not just in the new casting
decisions but remaking the whole movie
because she says that Snow White is
dated the cartoon was made 85 years ago
and therefore it's extremely dated and
so when we came to reimagining the
actual role of Snow White it became
about the fairest of the mall meaning
who is the most just and who can become
a fantastic leader Snow White has to
learn a lot of lessons about coming into
her own power before she can come into
power over a kingdom she says they
rewrote the story because Snow White is
extremely dated what does that mean to
be dated she's saying it like it's a bad
thing isn't it only bad for a thing to
be dated if the time that we're living
in is better than the time that the
dated thing existed